Scot thanks to you we had to run
we're still running you gotta go now
ant-man and the wasp we start to play
with the whole notion of scale shrinking
growing as a visual concept as a sci-fi
D as a super her idea is so cool one of
the ideas of this film is that they
exported shrinking and growing beyond
just suits to people suddenly cars can
shrink entire buildings country it's a
film about being on the run and about
being chased as a filmmaker you're
always looking to up your game about
everything we're gonna double down on
all the things that we liked in the
first movie there's a lot of play with
the scale it's gonna be a cautious that
is a little bit different from the
countries you've seen before you have
all these cars intersecting and hitting
each other and shrinking and growing
we're gonna die
what'd I miss we were just tiny I love
you dr. P we've taken the Hyundai
Veloster they told us that we could do
whatever we wanted to it to turn it into
what we needed to do this car has to be
cool and it has to be memorable
awesome
I thought it was a perfect car and
almost more of a dream for police to
drive
scope of this film is so much bigger
than the first film there's gonna be a
lot more oh my god moments in this one
we're doing car jumps we're doing car
flips
and man in the wasp teaming up
I wish I had a suit I would even like
like a suit with like minimal powers you
know or maybe even just a suit with no
powers
you